let's go get this money
you might know the social media app
tick-tock for its viral dance videos
or is the distinctly modern springboard
to fame here's a tax loophole that
actually works but recently it's also
become a popular platform
for millennials and gen zers to put
their entrepreneurial spirit into action
you probably won't believe this really
weird side hustle whether it's pitching
a side hustle so basically long story
short i resold
gently used clothing bragging about an
econ business i've made over a million
dollars on shopify and this is how i
started or documenting a real estate
investment
i bought an entire mobile home park
about a year and a half ago where this
tick tock subculture
is all about making money a super easy
way to make money
at home or at least teaching you how you
can too here's talked about your first
house using no bank
no cash and no credit search the side
hustle or entrepreneur on tick tock
and you'll find yourself in a vast sea
of self-help how to make 200
per hour just by removing background
images new entrepreneurs
are getting into everything from
affiliate marketing investing
let's do a refresher on what a dividend
is no matter the business model
you can probably find someone on tick
tock who is doing it you will not
believe the profit of this home flip
according to tick tock hashtag
entrepreneur has accrued more than 7.2
billion views
while hashtag side hustle has more than
4.7 billion views
this is the business side of tick tock
so can this corner of one of the world's
most popular social media apps
actually make you a successful
entrepreneur this is
a community of mostly young people
coming together and saying
how do we make some money nader ali
zadeh is the ceo of linkia
a marketing firm that specializes in
connecting brands with social media
influencers
i think if you're a young person trying
to get a job
today versus 12 months ago
it is significantly harder there's no
more opportune time
to be involved in trying to come up with
a side hustle than now what do you do
for a living
yeah what do you do i'm a drop shipper
one popular tick tock hustle
is drop shipping warning that's how 24
year old austin robin
says he makes between 30 and 40 000 in
profit a month
selling consumer goods i wanted to start
just to
provide tips in the e-commerce community
because i know what i was starting out
i didn't really have any go-to channel
or source that i used to answer my
questions
drop shipping is a business model that
allows online retailers to sell products
to their customers
without ever actually stocking the items
themselves
instead when a customer visits a
dropshipper's store
they're purchasing the item from a third
party that ships it directly
to the customer from there you'll
typically run
advertisements to get traffic onto your
store there's a couple different ways
one would be facebook advertisements
which includes instagram that's really
the main source for drop shippers
this right here is probably the number
one austin started using tick tock in
august
since then he has built his channel to
more than 766
000 likes and more than 82 000 followers
two of his videos have gotten more than
one million views
there's so much organic reach on tick
tock just the way that the whole
platform works is insane i think that's
why a lot of people are attracted to the
platform because you can
essentially become some sort of internet
sensation overnight
the two primary ways people make money
on tick tock are through its creator
marketplace
which connects ticktalkers with brands
and its creator fund
a one billion dollar pot of money tick
tock is using to pay its most popular
creators for their views
but most tick tockers can't make a
living just off tick tock
that's because brands gravitate to the
top creators with the biggest followings
and even if their videos rack up tens or
hundreds of thousands of views
users report low or inconsistent payouts
to date tick tock has not explained
exactly how it calculates payouts
from the creator fund robin said 95
of his income comes from drop shipping
but thanks to his growing tick tock
audience
he has managed to start a variety of
small side hustles i think it's in my
tick tock bios
in his tick tock bio robin provides
links to a variety of promotions
pre-built dropshipping websites and
access to private consultant services
for those who want to learn how to sell
buy this house for 500 000 and the bank
offered me a 15-year or a 30-year
mortgage
that potential to quickly build a large
audience
is also what attracted another tick tock
entrepreneur humphry yang to the
platform
yang specializes in sharing practical
personal finance advice
at the end of 2019 i made a decision to
make 30 days
of tick tocks in a row but by the end of
the 30 days i had over 120 000 followers
and i just never looked back
today yang's tick tock channel has 1.1
million followers
and 15.7 million likes but he said
those numbers aren't enough to make a
living off the platform
although he occasionally does some
sponsored posts on tiktok
yang said he sees the app as more of a
marketing tool
than a revenue stream i do view tech
talk as
more of a audience builder
um awareness top of funnel so basically
anybody that sees me for the first time
they might see me first on tick tock
and then they might get into my other
social channels youtube for example or
instagram
where they can learn a little bit more
about finance if they wish
since it launched in september 2016
ticktock has seen breakneck growth
being downloaded over 2 billion times on
the app store and google play
today it's one of the web's most
downloaded apps on par with other social
media giants like whatsapp
instagram and facebook tiktok has more
than 50 million daily us users
or roughly 15 percent of the us
population
even mine but the benefits of getting on
tick tock aren't just the potential to
grow a large audience
it's been fantastic for me networking so
that community
uh that we're talking about in that
specific hashtag i've connected with a
lot of those big guys on there
that have similar followings or bigger
followings than me and they offer me
tips just on the side of private
messages i will frequently receive
messages from people
saying that because they watch my videos
they decide to take more responsibility
in their own personal financial life
and those are quite fulfilling to
actually see that
my videos are spurring action being an
influencer is not for everybody
this is about independent of the number
of followers that you have
how can you go out and and make money
five dollars